hi patio lack a marketing and designer  and here they are a few things that  perhaps you don't know about people to  keep couriers to watch to smell and to  hear the society continuously time well  to lose perspective and to lose the  original concept in the process  Oh a tool for communicate that doesn't  fall down that doesn't break and that  doesn't give me problems to me health  curiosity evolution use your failures in  a positive way to start a day with  people I love a book I'm never afraid  perhaps of an empty fridge and I'm very  comfortable cooking at the end of high  school my mother make me a present of  lessons with a conceptual artist and  it's been a fantastic director or  something like this I I I miss always  the capacity of novelties there